Hello, this is Dr. Kevin Conner, welcome to module one of our stop fighting cancer course,
where we're going to go over some major pieces that you want to address as a cancer patient or
somebody who's trying not to become a cancer patient so that you can best take care of your body in
the most natural approach, whether you still have to do some standards of care or not or you've
exhausted that avenue, we have patients that come to us for all sorts of reasons. Many don't want
to go the standards of care approach and we understand that. Some have to because their
cancer is growing quickly and they want to add integratively a natural approach and we understand
that and some have not even thought about a natural slash alternative approach and they let
straight down the standards of care aisle which is the most common thing to do. It's a very
scary thing getting a cancer diagnosis and many people especially if they're not regularly naturally
minded in the first place don't even have an open mind to natural things and tell a standards
of care approach and the failing and they are told that there's not a whole lot that they can do
except maybe palliative chemo or something like that and that doesn't interest them and they're now
they're starting to look at natural things. Well we want to be careful to use natural things wisely as
well in this module I'm calling the natural band-aid approach because we can use natural things like a
band-aid two. Still not really addressing the cause, still not really addressing the reason
why the person is in the state that they're in. We're just going to use a bunch of natural things
kind of the same way as you'd use medication and a lot of functional quote-unquote functional medicine
doctors or quote-unquote natural paths or quote-unquote natural modalities really do that. They're
they're maybe using nutraceuticals maybe using herbs maybe using vitamins or homeopathy but still not
digging in underneath to dig into the cause. They're still using it kind of like you'd use medicine.
I have a headache. I'm going to take some Tylenol. Well don't take Tylenol. Take some white
willobark instead. Well I guess it's better you know than doing drugs that have all these negative
side effects but shouldn't you dig in to find out why you have the headache in the first place?
Not that you wouldn't do those things. Not that you wouldn't still use some curcumin or white willobark
or buswellie or something for your headache but we're still using it as a band-aid. We don't want to
make that mistake and that's really what this module's about. To a natural band-aid approach can be
the same as a medical band-aid approach. I guess there's nothing wrong with band-dates. You need to
cover the wound. You need to deal with the symptoms at hand but you need to find out why you did it.
If you continue to put a band-aid on a wound because you're touching a hot stove and you don't stop
touching the hot stove we're going to run out of band-dates pretty quick. Silly analogy but we tend
to do that in our medical system. That's really what the medical system is set up as. You don't go to
the medical doctor and tell you have a problem and then they go there and they have a solution to
that problem. Well currently in the last 50 years the only solution to that problem is here take this
drug as if you have a deficiency in a drug. Well natural care can't go in towards that too like I
suggest it and we don't want to just do that without finding out why the problem is there and looking
for a solution by fixing the Y. One of our bottles and our clinic for years has been looking for
the reason why. There's always a reason why. Well sometimes the reason why is more difficult than
other times to uncover. It's easy when you're touching a hot stove to know that while I'm touching
the hot stove that's why I burn it myself I guess I'll stop that. But when you have cancer or some
serious disease like that the reason why is a little bit more insidious to figure out so we need to
do some digging and some testing to do that. But a natural approach a natural approach to a mandate
approach is really not a whole lot different than a medical approach. There's benefits to mandates. There
are sometimes you have to do surgery. When you're talking about cancer, debugging surgery sometimes can
be extremely beneficial and can be necessary. Using chemotherapy can sometimes be beneficial and can
sometimes be necessary. I know that's hard to hear that coming out of the mouth of an alternative
practitioner. But that's reasonable. There's times when chemotherapy, radiation, surgery is the
right thing to do. And I think taking a dogmatic position either way is equally wrong. When I hear
of an oncologist that poo-poo's alternative care and that's the only thing you should do is standards
of care that's speaking out of just pure ignorance. But I also think when you hear an alternative doctor
that says I would never do standards of care and chemotherapy just kills people it's a poison
it's all it does. Well true it is a poison but it can kill the cancer. And hopefully before it
kills the patient and it can debulk a cancer when the cancer is actively growing. Same thing with surgery
debulking it can be the right thing to do. So don't let anybody tell you what's right or wrong
for you. That's a personal decision that you have to make upon doing a lot of investigation and talking
to a lot of different people. There's wisdom in a multitude of counselors. I think it's best that you
have counselors that aren't taking a dogmatic approach that are looking at you like an individual
and seeing what's the best thing for you to do. And then of course everybody's advice is going to
be biased but take each person's advice from different categories of health care and then you can balance
that out and hopefully bring it to the Lord and know what is the best approach for you. So there's
benefits of mandates. They're necessary. They can help heal wounds. They can protect us from further
assault. Then there's benefits to using that approach with cancer but it can't be our only thing.
If it is we're doomed to just the results that standards of care are going to give us without digging
any deeper. So we want to look at the drawbacks of cancer when we're only going to use a therapy for
cancer without digging in to what are the causes, how to clean up the environment, how to fix the
energy and the frequencies behind the scene, how to fix why the cells are acting that way. Look at the
genetics of the cells. Not just here this gene causes cancer because that usually doesn't exist
but the genetics of metabolism around it so that we can deal with that in a more holistic way.
The farther you can take a step back and look at your body and how to correct what's going on in your
body and why it's happening the better results you're going to have. It's not a perfect approach. There
is not a perfect approach and if any practitioner tells you that they can cure cancer in some way
I'd run away from them as fast as I could so but cancer is a complex disease. Matter of fact each
cancer is very different. Matter of fact you could say every single person with cancer is a unique
disease. So if you look at it that way and you look uniquely at your needs you're going to get better
results. So we don't want to just throw a bunch of supplements and nutraceuticals at a person
to try to help them with cancer. That's just as wrong as throwing a bunch of drugs at a person
to help them with cancer. And we certainly don't want to just get our information about different
nutraceutical approaches off of different media out there because there's a lot of bad information
out there. I see different posts on social media that says, well if you take curcumin or whatever
it kills 98% of cancers in a test tube. Well you know pretty much purified water is going to kill
98% of cancer cells in a test tube because they'll just die. They don't, it's not an living environment.
So be careful of false claims out there, be careful of just both face lies out there for the purpose
of selling a bunch of supplements. It's misleading at best and unethical in my book and just be careful
of that. I have patients that come to us that are literally taking well over 100 to 200 supplements
a day. I don't know how your liver could even deal with that. That's not even good for us. So
take a step back and get as specific as you can find a practitioner that will get specific for you
and what your needs are that will do different tests. That's what we're trying to promote. We don't
want everybody to come to us but we want everybody to look at their body differently and uniquely
so that they'll get the best results possible. You have to get to the root, you have to get to the cause.
There are so many possible causes of cancer. What we're finding today is most causes of cancer
are environmental. There are pesticides and chemicals in our environment that even if you're
eating organic and doing all the right things, you're still going to be exposed to these things. These
get inside the cell and cause the cell to replicate and then the next coming modules will dig deeper into
that and how to deal with that but you have to deal with those root things if you really want to change
the environment enough to be able to heal the person. So just think about it. Typically our medical
profession, you know, you could call it germ theory but you could call it, you know, this theory
that there's something wrong with the body and something on the outside if we inject it into the body
or if we do it infusion into the body or if we give a drug to the body then we'll fix it without
understanding that the terrain, the environment of that person and even that emotional environment
in that person is really what you really need to fix. Not that you shouldn't do an injection
or that you shouldn't use a supplement or that you shouldn't use a drug but if you don't clean up
the terrain, if you don't clean up the environment, we're just not going to get as good a result.
So even if you're choosing, you feel like God is leading you to do a standard of care approach
at least add on the natural things that can dig into cleaning up the environment,
cleaning up your body, cleaning up why it's there in the first place, dealing with the emotional
wounds that you've had in the past so that you can clean up that fish tank and you're going to get
the best results possible and even if you do a medical approach that that drug is going to work
better under a better environment. That's what our whole idea with these modules is and we're
going to dig deep into it and give you some really usable advice on how to take those steps.
So hold on with us as we go through this. I hope this is going to be a huge blessing
to a lot of people so you know when everybody can come to us, not even a lot of people don't even have
a practitioner dear than they can deal with nor can they even afford a practitioner. That's why
we tried to make this very reasonable so you can take this information and go with it. So hold on
through these modules and we'll see you in module two.